In this next quiz I'd like you to extend your software to print out the optimal policy.
That's happened over here.
If we look at the grid, there's an obstacle over here.
There's a T-shaped obstacle over here.
The goal is in the bottom right corner.
Obviously to get the goal, over here you want to go down
as indicated by these v's over here--down, down, down, down, down.
Up here you'll want to go either right or down.
Down here, in this little dead end, you want to go left, left, then up, and then right again
into this passage over here, up again over here, right, and down, down, down.
The optimal policy is ambiguous.
Sometimes there are multiple optimal actions.
For example, up here you go right or down.
For other places like the ones over here, it's not ambiguous.
There's only one optimal thing to do, which is going down.
I want you to write code that outputs this policy,
which is in many ways very similar to the path output by A-star.